[Music]
my name is Caitlin and I am from
Plainview New York and why a big brother
Caitlin I love this show I've been
watching for like five years which isn't
like I wouldn't say I'm like a superfan
because that just doesn't qualify but I
really like the show so much and I kind
of always just envisioned to myself
since the second I started watching it
on the show so I kind of manifested this
reality and it's just so wild so now
you're here yeah and for Big Brother
twenty nine and a big season it's gonna
be huge
do you have any hopes for what the
twists might be this year like no
because here's the thing like it's gonna
be bad like it's like Noah its season 20
they're obviously gonna do something
like outrageous which is just like just
like giving me anxiety but I just have a
feeling and I could be wrong but like I
feel like season 20 they're gonna do 20
house casts and like just do something
or like the some there's got to be
something with the number 20 I'm really
also hoping that this is like the first
season they give us like a little more
than five hundred thousand is a grand I
feel like there might be a little bit I
feel like there will be like a few more
opportunities to win money or just like
prizes in general hoping to see like a
lot of like guests come in or like maybe
some some famous people like Bobby
Moynihan or like Cathy you know oh you
want to see the celebrity superfans yeah
would you want to see any vets return to
the game I wouldn't I mean here's the
thing like if we're being probabl like I
feel like it's gonna happen but like as
a fan and just like seeing what other
fans write it like nobody wants that I
certainly don't but it just seems like
that you so like sure if someone did
walked in who would you want to see like
Donnie or Kevin just like I'd like like
an older uncle kind of vibe like yeah
just like a non-threatening the
situation would be nice for me so like
Donnie you're Kevin yeah and on the flip
side is there someone you would be like
oh god why are they here
like Poli caliph Yuri like if you walked
in I'd be like it's just like totally
necessary CBS but yeah that's the only
one I could pick up you know the time I
take it great
now this game can get kind of vicious
sure how vicious will you get inside
that house not very I mean I think that
there's a way to like be successful and
not be you know a psychopath or vicious
that's like the way I live my life and
I'm a very honest person and I follow
the whole love and light kind of thing
so there's just no need I want to be
able to like prove to people you can win
this game and not be a total you know
psycho put positive energy out yeah
positive will come back exactly yeah
good part of that being putting positive
out the showmance
there's no way not only am I like in a
five-year committed relationship but
even if I wasn't
that's just like not why you go on the
show and if you get like the amazing
opportunity to come on this show like
you're wasting your time I feel and like
don't get me wrong like love will
prevail and like the sanctity of love is
beautiful but like we're here like
playing a game and that's just like so
it's change it strange to me surprised
and is money not yeah like this is an
aria the one what does the significant
other at home think about you coming and
doing this he thinks this is really
funny like he never watched an episode
in his life and then when the Serbs
become like a serious conversation like
I put on an episode he'd get like so
invested and we like talking to that to
the TV so I could just so imagine him
you like Kaitlyn like enough watching
the live feeds this summer like he's
telling he's like I'm busy but like
you're gonna be watching and like so is
my I'm more concerned for my father who
like owns a business it's like that's
spiraling straight down like he's not
maybe wants to do anything yeah this
shows a way of um pulling stuff out of
the woodwork yeah is there anything
you're nervous might come out about your
past like not know I'm such an open book
like there's there's nothing I
done in my life though I wish like I
wished or scared no less like maybe like
one person from middle school would be
like healin was so rude to me when she
was like the lead in the school play and
I was ensemble be in my life
she wrote like that would be so like
actually horrible if someone like kept
that with them but hilarious going into
the house yourself is there anything
you're gonna keep a secret from the
other house game yeah yeah I mean I'm a
certified life coach and meditation
instructor but my whole like intuitive
reading and picking up on energies and
seeing auras like that is something
that's not only so new to me this has
only been about a year and a half of
doing this and it just came about so I'm
still even like oh my god like is this
for real
but unfortunately it is it's my truth
but it's not necessarily like I know
that there are people that are skeptical
to that type of stuff and they are so
allowed to be I just don't really need
to hear it I don't need someone like
time you like you're full of it like I
don't care enough I don't and it'll also
help me like make my decisions and kind
of weave my way around the game so
sometime in the last two years you just
kind of this gift just presented itself
you know what I wouldn't say within the
past two years I think I've always like
had this thing but ignoring it like
hardcore ignoring it um I kind of like
lived in this like ego you know base
world like I was in high school and I
was cool and this and that and even in
college it continued and you know when I
graduated college and I was a music
major never thought I would be doing
coaching when I made my way up pretty
quickly in the music industry and I
realize this is not for me and I started
getting really into you know self-help
and this and that and it just gradually
developed and I say that we all have the
ability to do these things you're just
not gonna tap into it if you're not open
to it and it's I mean it's so bizarre my
parents are like who
do we race no like who did we raise so
what's the cover story gonna be just
like hey I'm like the guy to medicate
medication my meditation instructor
there's really nothing else like there
is no story like there is no nothing
it's not gonna let on that maybe you're
homeless I'll definitely talk about in
the diary room though
that's the place the aura of this person
is so and so tonight but not to them
that'll be fascinating me here I'll be
so fun it's like shady but not really
but not really now if it's what your
senior saying you are potentially going
away for three whole months yeah
what are you gonna miss most about the
outside world honestly like aside from
my family my boyfriend and all of that
like just like seeing what's going on in
the world not even like pop culture-wise
like me it's like 2018 and there's just
way too much going on and the fact that
like I even have this opportunity to be
of like somewhat of like an influencer
in this world and I get to like come
into the show and bring like love and
light and positivity like I'm stoked for
that because even if there's just one
person watching that I could like
influence to maybe shift their
perception or shift their mindset or
like see something through like a lens
of love like that's great I just I hope
the rest of the world is just doing the
same when I'm in the house I like just
positive positive positive
is there anything though that you're
kind of excited not to have to deal with
for three months
sure like just like general chores like
the generally buying gas and that's
groceries and like life stuff just like
life stuff like I have a bank account
like I'm just not spend any money um no
but like you know just like little
things like that like I feel like this
is such a hardcore experience but like
we are well taken care of and at least
I've ever worked over my head and I'm
getting fed and yeah like that'll be
nice no Big Brother is a lot about lying
yeah is that gonna be tough for you I'm
not going to like and that's the other
thing like I say that now and of course
it's easier said than done
let's fast forward three months from now
and I'm lying to Africa but like I
genuinely am going into this like I want
to prove to people that you don't need
to be like a lying you know crazy
manipulative person to win this game
like you can be an authentic person and
how badly does this world me that like
imagine like I come out on top and I'm
just like a nice gal that was something
I mean it would be so epic like I'm just
manifesting for that it would be really
really good all right so why are you
going to win this show Oh first of all I
have no doubt in my mind like I'm going
to win the show and I think it's because
like within the stressful environment
people are going to want someone around
that can kind of like calm people down
or like just you know make them feel
like they're at peace in some way
because this is a really unique and
crazy experience so if there's just that
one person that like can help you like
give you know take that deep breath or
like a line you or take out my essential
oil and make sure your sinuses are clear
that's great but like I'm sure to play
an honest game and I really really think
that that's gonna help me win this this
whole thing all right is the aura good
in this room yeah really good actually
it was like cold before and I was like
cranky but now I'm feeling great
it's great yeah yeah you are as good
[Music]
[Applause]